un papel con el que los franceses están
muy familiarizados pero desde este lunes
ya no es necesario este documento para
justificar los desplazamientos de más de
10 kilómetros me va muy bien me irá el
próximo fin de semana ahora muy bien a
todo el mundo era desesperadamente
necesario
los domingos podríamos pasear más allá
de los bosques parisinos
y podremos visitar a nuestros familiares
que viven lejos
los viajes interregionales vuelven a
estar permitidos y la frecuencia de los
trenes aumentará progresivamente durante
las próximas semanas
mientras tanto 6 millones de estudiantes
de secundaria regresan a las aulas pero
con el objetivo de mantener la distancia
social en las clases algunos de ellos
seguirán la mitad de sus cursos desde
casa los centros educativos recibirán
millones de auto test que los profesores
deben hacerse dos veces por semana si
continúa siendo mejor que cerrar los
colegios por completo aún si bien que se
fue con fiambres y tenis toscos sabemos
que cada vez que los cerramos dejamos
atrás a los estudiantes más vulnerables
y las desigualdades aumentan es el
primer paso para la reapertura gradual
de francia la siguiente fase de
desconfía miento será entre el 13 y el
17 de mayo cuando el toque de queda se
retrase hasta las 9 de la noche y habrán
comercios no esenciales terrazas y
lugares culturales